so we are picking up right where we left
off I hope your brain is kind of like
whoa those are some weird crazy big
ideas this morning and I hope you see
why I began the way that I did but at
the moment what we've been kind of
talking about it's like you know who say
but was really like this and like wait
you did that and you know a lot of the
things we're describing it's difficult
to talk about because we don't have
precise language so we are going to
introduce a whole bunch of terms some of
them you met this morning and I just
want to get them all in context but
there's also going to be some new ones
and also some new notation because words
are cool but if math is known for one
thing it's that we replace them as
quickly as you can with symbols because
in their faster to work with okay so
let's start at the top do you remember
we were looking at the graph right and
we said okay rise over run and we looked
at the triangle all that kind of thing
we said rise over run we would normally
call gradient but then we introduced a
super fancy name for that we called it
the the difference quotient the
difference quotient and it's a fancy
phrase but it is what it says it's
measuring differences like how far did
you go here how fast how far did he run
what's the difference between this
moment in time and this moment in time
grab to say quickly so it's about
measuring differences but it's not just
measuring differences what we're doing
is we're dividing rise over run or
vertical change over horizontal change
that's a question when you divide things
okay so we did say it is a gradients but
it's not just any gradient
it's the gradient of this line that cuts
your particular function your particular
graph add a couple of spots what did we
call that kind of line a secant or a
second right I literally have no idea
how it's meant to be pronounced but we
know what we're talking about this is a
line that slices across the graph at two
distinct points bless you so that was a
difference question right but then right
at the very end and I sort of did it
with some a bit of hand waving and I did
it quite quickly
we talked about what happened if you
took these two points which were H units
apart horizontally and we said what if
you compress that H into like zero what
if you said those two points were not
separate but the same what I did was I
took that same difference question
and instead of just evaluating that
fraction and simplifying right we did a
whole bunch of algebra that what we did
was we said what if we could take the
limit as H approaches zero where is it
going right this idea of a limit bless
you takes this H sort of out of the
equation right so what happens is you no
longer get the gradient of a secant as
you can see here and please draw this
diagram next to your words as well we
get a different gradient will you get
the gradient or something else namely
the starts with a T the tangent and why
is it called a tangent again tangent
tell what is tangent mean yeah it just
touches as if it's like tangent is about
is about touching like tangible right so
we said that's what we got and what was
interesting about this was when we did
our gradients of secrets you just got
numbers like negative 5 and negative 1
or 3 or something like that but then
when we worked out the gradient of the
tangent it had X's inner do you remember
that well did not exes it had one X now
this is actually and it was right at the
end so I kind of glossed over it this is
actually a really big freaking deal
right because now we're not just looking
at individual numbers when looking at
the gradient and it changes depending on
where you are which makes sense because
like some bits are steep and going down
some bits are shallow or just flat
across what was the gradient by the way
when it's flat across gradient zero
because there's no rise and there's the
run down so here's this weird idea right
that the gradient will you calculate it
is no longer just a number the gradient
itself is a function thank you right the
gradient is a function it's not just a
number which you can say boom there it
is eight or something like that the
gradients a function that changes in
response to what value of x you put in
there okay now being it is itself a
function I'm going to use function
notation to describe it now I could just
call it like if this red thing was f of
X actually might write that if this red
thing was f of X I could call the other
gradient function something else G of X
if you like but I want to capture
that the gradient function is related to
this original function so instead of
giving it a whole separate name I'm
going to call it f dash X so that -
indicates hey hey hey this is related to
f of X that's where I came from
f dash X is a way of indicating a
function not just any function it's the
gradient function of f of X whatever
that happened to be let's point started
off with x squared minus 4x and this is
what we've landed with okay now because
this gradient function it comes from the
original function we give it another
name and you might have heard this one
thrown around a little bit by your year
12 friends we call it the derivative
because a derivative literally means it
came from something else right it's like
you know sugar is a derivative of the
cane plant right like they're processing
they get to stuff as I hear it is a
derivative okay
so the derivative comes through your
original function and from now on we're
going to use these phrases and words
interchangeably we might say hey find
the gradient function calculate
determine what the derivative is okay
they both mean the same thing
find this F dash X this 2x minus 4 in
this case okay now the last bit of
language we get introduced just for now
is well what is that process called when
you're finding the derivative where
you're finding the gradient function
okay
remember there's all that differences
right try to calculate how fast is
something changing moving from something
to something different okay so the
process of going from your original
function to your derivative like getting
to that thing because it's all about
this difference question thing that's
where we started this process is called
differentiating say it again this
process of going from your original
function to what's the gradient function
what's the derivative it's called
differentiating or I guess the noun
would be differentiation okay
please note and this gets misused all
the time but even though it's called a
derivative
it's not called deriving that means
something completely different in
mathematics you know you could derive a
proof for something has nothing to do
with calculus this is the word that
we've got here if you want a sort of
anchor for why it's that think about
where we started this is all about
calculus is the mathematics of change
things becoming something to something
different
hence differentiation hold on which
thing in the middle this line so this
line indicates to me like the process of
going from a function to change that
into its derivative it's just it's just
a change right that change is called
differentiating make sense long word
thankfully you won't really have to
write it very much but you'll have to
say it and you will read it a whole
bunch okay